whoever be it who Stacks plates if they
be worthy
have the body of Thor
[Music]
so
this isn't topical like at all it's
actually quite out of season I I mean
I'm gonna largely be talking about
something that happened years ago but
might have still been slightly topical
if I decided to talk about this back
when Thor love and thunder first hit
theaters or even if I'd done it when
Thor 11 Thunder first hit streaming
I didn't I missed the window but I still
want to talk about it anyways partially
because it's going to be my opportunity
to sort of address a little bit
something of a bigger issue but look at
what I think is one of the more
interesting and closest to Nuance that
these things tend to get examples of it
so I want to talk about fat Thor from
Avengers end game now I am going to be
using the term fat fairly often in this
video now if you find that term
offensive
I'm just giving you the heads up now it
is the term used most often by fat
Liberation Advocates partially to try
and take the stigma off it it's a
descriptor it's not an insult inherently
or at least it shouldn't be and taking
the stigma off that is something that we
really should be striving for
but the reason I want to talk about this
is because there is frankly a lot of
conversation to be had in general about
fat phobia in our culture and especially
our entertainment and our media and
there is just so much work being done
Often by fat Liberation Advocates who
have to advocate for themselves because
even medical professionals have such a
bias against those who are heavy that
they will tell someone who comes in
complaining of symptoms that have
absolutely nothing to do with their
weight to go and go on a diet rather
than actually take their health
complaints seriously the
misunderstanding and the demonization of
anyone over a certain prescribed weight
is a massive problem but it's also a
bigger problem than somebody like me is
equipped to really tackle and honestly
while I don't consider myself to be
skinny I'm not at a point where I think
calling myself fat comes off as much
more than possibly unnecessary
self-deprecation so again I'm not thin
I'm actually close to the heaviest I've
ever been and I've been around this
weight for a little while but I'm also
very happy with my body not that fat
people can't be they absolutely can be
and should be allowed to be if they are
but my point is is that I feel weird
calling myself that so this is me
acknowledging I'm kind of a little bit
stepping outside my Lane now I've done
that before I did a video on disability
representation but that was a broader
Overlook of some of the problems that
happen with it this I kind of want to
funnel some discussions that it will
touch on a number of points of some of
the issues with some of the specific
things that go on with Hollywood
depictions but this is not a broad
overview I am filtering this
specifically through the lens of Chris
Hemsworth as Thor in the way he was
depicted in end game the first thing
that I want to point out as to why I'm
choosing this in particular I kind of
alluded to it before I feel that there's
actually a bit more Nuance to this and
it's actually Nuance that was brought to
my attention by friends of mine who are
fat and did actually like this when I
first saw this in the theater I rolled
my eyes out I was like oh God are we
really doing this but then
people I knew would later tell me and
I'll give you some of the reasons they
gave me explain why they actually liked
this and while I don't think anybody
praised it as like an amazing Great
Piece of fat representation in
entertainment there's still some
problems with it there are reasons to
like this despite it also exemplifying
some of the classic problems and by
illustrating both where it succeeds and
where it fails I'm hoping I can kind of
nudge you towards some of the bigger
problems that are going on as well but
as I said right now we're focusing in on
this so to remind you following the
events of infinity War where Thor took a
lot of personal responsibility for his
failure to kill Thanos before Thanos did
the snap
he basically just sat around he went
into a depressive State and he gained a
notable amount of weight in doing so
so let's deal with the elephant in the
room first
they put Chris Hemsworth in a fat suit
and frankly that is a practice that by
and large really needs to go away
putting thin or uh fit or just someone
who isn't of that body type at all in a
fat suit especially if it is leaned on
for comedy which this frequently is in
this depiction is something that just
needs to stop
now some people may claim well you know
sometimes they need somebody to for you
know for the story to look even heavier
than you know they would be able to find
an actor for fine
a fat actor and put them in a fat suit
they're gonna understand what it's like
to be something closer to what they're
depicting oh but they're actors they can
play everything look I'm not gonna delve
forever into the fat suit thing but
there is surprisingly in a way a similar
issue to thin people playing fat
characters in terms of what it says at a
meta level subconsciously about fat
people to the problem that there is with
cisgender people playing transgender
characters which is that whether the
narrative itself is saying it or not
there is subconsciously an instillment
of the idea that fat people are really
just thin people underneath and flatly
that's a harmful idea I know there's a
lot of people out there that think it's
helpful this idea of oh well there's a
thin person in there are just trying to
get out look first of all it feeds into
an automatic assumption that if somebody
is over a certain body weight they must
want to not be that and that is not a
fair assumption to make I actually
brought this up when I talked about
disability before in that previous video
an inclination towards tragic framing
may be rooted in the perspectives of
people without disabilities viewing them
from the outside I mean honestly it's a
bit like a straight guy saying
I don't get what's so appealing about
kissing another man
of course you don't because you're not
gay so along those same lines the
perception of I don't see how anyone
with a disability could see it as
anything other than tragic
well of course he can't because it's not
your life or your experience it's a
mentality that defaults to the idea that
being fat is an inherently bad or
undesirable thing this contributes a
great deal to Fat shaming many of the
people who do this will say that what we
are concerned about your health first of
all somebody else's health is really
none of your business and second of all
even if somebody had a desire to lose
weight whether it was for health related
reasons or not they might not be able to
some people don't have the ability or
the means to do the diet and exercise to
attain a lower body weight than they
have some people's genetics are just
never going to accommodate them being
something that most society would accept
as skinny or fit and some people because
of their genetics they can't get that in
a healthy way and encouraging them to do
it in an unhealthy way is you know
unhealthy besides the fact that you can
actually be healthy at almost any weight
but this idea
that oh there's really just a skinny
person out of there we if we worked on
it we could get them out from under all
that that is subconsciously implanted
because that's what the actor is the
actor is a thinner person buried under
all the stuff that can be taken off and
as I made the comparison with when CIS
people play trans actors it instills the
idea that trans people are really
cisgender people just pretending and
maybe like with makeup and wigs and all
this other stuff and it instills that
idea because that's what the actor's
doing even if it's not part of the
narrative doing that sends that as a
subconscious meta piece of text so it's
just a bad thing that should stop
that having been said there is a unique
aspect to doing it here with Thor that
is not at play in most instances of fat
suits being used which is 99 of the time
when a fat suit is used first of all
part of the reason they are getting a
thin actor is because well not very many
uh fat actors ever get used enough to
become a big enough star to be
considered viable to front a movie so
there's that but in addition to that if
there were more well-established like
high PR High um profile fat actors most
of them wouldn't take these roles
because they're insulting inherently and
it's a lot easier to get somebody to
play an insulting role if they're not
actually part of the group that's being
insulted so you know that's that is a a
frequent issue with a lot of
representation whether it's intended to
be comedic or not when you cast someone
who is not part of the group being
represented they are not going to know
if what is being portrayed crosses a
line so there's that and also as I
alluded to before the vast majority of
times we're dealing with the fat suit
we're dealing with
comedies and I put a pause there because
boy
is fat humor really played out and
really tired and really cruel and really
boring
there's three jokes oh they're hungry
even though they're so fat oh they broke
a chair or if it's exceptionally
aggressed oh the fat one farted
[Music]
oh my god oh they can taste it yeah I
don't have a lot of use for fat humor at
this point just because it's incredibly
rare to find a fat joke not told by a
fat person that isn't just the laziest
stuff that we've heard a million times
over but
with Thor in endgame it's not strictly
comedic and we'll kind of come back to
the comedy level of it and what else is
going on but in regards to the use of a
fat suit specifically we have here an
established character who prior to this
was probably never intended to be of a
body type that we see in end game and so
since Chris Hemsworth already is this
part then there is a better argument to
be made about employing a fat suit here
there's still an argument to be had over
whether this should whether this move
with the character and making him fat
should be happening at all but if you
are not going to Hardline that then you
have to at least admit there is more
cause to use it here than there is
normally because normally
no
normally like it's either just somebody
in a fat suit doing awful jokes or
sometimes they'll do a similar thing to
again trans people where they'll be like
oh but we need to show them back when
they were skinnier or we need to show a
skinny person back when they were fat
and so we have to put them in a fat suit
and they'll say that about trans
characters oh but what about when we
want to show them back when they weren't
trans back when they were cisgender
why do you need that
do you really need that
because I would push back on the
majority of times that you claim that oh
but we have to have this do you
do you really
how much funnier quote unquote was just
friends for the clumsy awkward fat jokes
that existed for the flashbacks with
Ryan Reynolds in a freaking fat suit
I mean I suppose you could argue they
weren't much less funny than the rest of
the movie was but
at that point you just gotta say scrap
the whole thing which would not have
been a bad idea All Things Considered
but anyways
so that's kind of getting to why I want
to talk about this there's a lot more
Nuance here that I think allows for some
exploration of why there are some rules
of thumb that probably should be obeyed
as we examine maybe why not all of them
apply here or at least what the argument
could be for them to not apply here
now I did say that this is an issue of
Thor being depressed and
this is actually another little bit of
an issue while depression eating is very
much a thing and it can contribute to
weight gain
it's not the sole cause and Hollywood
has a tendency to go to overeating as a
form of depression as a little bit of a
go-to image and that's not super helpful
either because again it implies that
while there's something wrong that's why
someone is fat as opposed to just you
know
having a fat person every now and then
no there must be a reason they are this
way and sometimes there is sometimes
it's medical sometimes it even is
connected to depression that is
something that can happen I'm not going
to say that it can't or never does
happen
but it doesn't happen in the proportion
that it gets depicted I can't stop
eating
I eat because I'm unhappy
but I'm unhappy because I eat this is
part of why and I'm sure Brendan Frazier
is great in it I don't doubt that it's
part of why I have zero interest in the
upcoming Oscar Bait movie The Whale I
have no interest in this because I've
read the synopsis and I have no interest
in seeing an actor buried in a fat suit
to depict someone who is depressed and
eating himself to death the acting could
very well be excellent I've heard it is
and I like Brendan Frazier I hope he
gets a legitimate career Resurgence on
the back of this I have no interest in
this movie stop
stop doing that
so that's another issue that's kind of
something of a problem with Thor being
this way because
of depression which again can and does
happen
but it is such a go-to
instance an example of why someone gains
weight in Hollywood that
it's kind of unhelpful and unhealthy to
continue to depict it as regularly as
they do even in things like frankly just
friends or you know the show Friends
with Monica flashbacks there's often
this implication that they were more
depressed when they were fat and they're
in some ways if not always in some ways
happier now
that's usually pretty common in those
depictions again linking it with
depression which yes fat people can be
depressed but one does not necessarily
follow on from the other we all have
reasons to be depressed now the
depression contributing to something of
a slovenly appearance on the part of
Thor is a little bit greasy a little bit
food stain that makes more sense as a
general thing it is fairly common for
people who are depressed to not take as
much
interest in their own appearance partly
just for lack of energy or feeling that
there's no point
but unfortunately that paired with the
weight gain
does this linking of slovenliness to
one's weight which is another Super
overplayed thing frequently for comedy
and speaking of the comedy in endgame
specifically it doesn't help that pretty
much none of the humor is allowed to
originate from Thor himself and it's
pretty much all quips made by his quote
unquote friends and the reason I put
that in quotes is they make quips and
jokes about his weight gain while
ignoring the fact that as presented in
this specific instance in framing that
weight gain is a manifestation of deeper
issues almost none of which these
characters are bothering to delve in or
take any consideration of Hulk seems to
be the most thoughtful in regards to
this but we get a whole lot of stuff
like this what do you think is coursing
through my veins right now cheers whiz
and that's not to say no jokes could be
made at his expense by other people Tony
Stark has a decent one when he refers to
Thor as Lebowski
because yeah he looks more than a little
bit like the dude from the big Lebowski
that's fair but most of the other jokes
and references are cheap shots you look
like melted ice cream
so those are kind of the core reasons
why I had an initial gut
reaction to it
but I said that I've had friends like
not just casual people people I know who
genuinely liked this
so I feel like I should express some of
the reasons that were explained to me
that yeah actually make a fair bit of
sense
part of it has to do with one specific
thing that end game
did not do
and that is that when Thor gets mjolnir
again and starts using these weapons
again
it doesn't immediately change him back
his weight had nothing to do with his
worthiness and in fact he even says
I actually really love this entire
interaction that he has with his mom
where she clearly can tell something is
wrong but she never brings up his weight
and I was so prepared to go off on how
great that is until this line was
slipped in at the very end
and I'm extra annoyed at that because
since she's not facing the camera
there's a very good chance that that was
a drop in line added after the fact but
sorry positive we're doing the positives
right now it would have been so easy
with the idea that once he gets like the
original mjolnir Hammer back in his hand
that it's just gonna revert him and that
would have been awful instead in the
entire final fight he kicks just as much
but he is actually has no moment that
even implies his fighting ability or his
heroism is in any way impaired by the
state of his body
and that's
great like honestly if we didn't have
the fat suit issue and the fact that the
character used to be skinny and that
it's implied that depression has caused
the weight gain if we remove that and
just deal with him in the climax you
have a fat superhero
doing amazing things incredible things
heroic things applaudible things kicking
ass looking cool being fat while he
doesn't that's what we need more of and
it'd be amazing if it wasn't tied to all
the other stuff that I've already talked
about but that also brings up me to the
other thing that some people said which
is some people again including some
friends of mine like fat Thor because
they now have a cosplay character
of a hero
a superhero
a cannon
superhero
that they can cosplay as
because normally if you are a fat
cosplayer
you are either restricted to a very
small number of characters or you're
seen as a variant you're not seen as
authentically cosplaying because you are
the fat version of blah whatever it is
you happen to be cosplaying now not
everyone's going to be that rude about
it but that's generally how you're
perceived you're perceived as not really
embodying the character but fat Thor's
Canon
that's not an alternate version of Thor
that's Thor
I have friends who have told me with
absolute joy in their voices
that they get to go around Comic-Con
with like the robe and the tank top and
just be themselves not feel like they
have to suck in a gut or you know have
to hide who they are or be ashamed of
who they are because they are that
character they get to just look like how
he looked on screen and it's fine people
love it they think it looks great and
I would never want to take that away
from them because there's precious
little options where you aren't viewed
as some alternate fat version of a
character as opposed to just being hey
it's the character I recognize that
exactly good cosplay and also relatively
easy cosplay if you've got a bathrobe
and you just got to get the sunglasses
the hammer either grow or put on a beard
and like you're pretty much done and it
was in hearing stories like that that
really gave me a better appreciation of
why something like this for all the
problems that it has can still have some
value
is it perfect absolutely not
does it still bring something that was
missing from the MCU
yeah it did until Thor love and thunder
came out now I'm actually on the record
as being one of the few people on the
internet who apparently liked Thor love
and thunder is my review right up there
but
I will admit it was disappointing to see
as part of a montage
Thor well as cork puts it he went from
I do appreciate that it is made clear
that he did have to put in the work for
it and again it wasn't just magically
dissolved and it gives an impression
that if you're going to try and lose
that weight yes there is serious work
and we're not just gonna gloss over it
because that's another thing that I kind
of skipped over with a lot of the fat
suit stuff especially when there's a
before and after sense and the after is
the skinny version that's just the actor
how they normally are you almost never
see that Journey ever instead you just
see them skinny and then you see them in
the fat suit and it's like oh boy that
was too bad oh this is so much better
and they don't show the work which gives
this impression of oh how hard could it
be they want from that to this great
awesome like no it's a montage granted
but it's made clear he put in the work
that's
good but I really wish they hadn't done
that
and to be clear I'm not even gonna say
that they should have kept him in the
fat suit because like I said there's
problems with that but you know what
would have been really cool
if they just
well if they just let Chris Hemsworth
let go a little bit if they didn't
insist he'd gone the workout regimen
that they've made him do for every
single one of these movies and they just
let him be whatever he's gonna be like
still muscular still buff but you know
maybe with a little bit of fat in front
of the ABS you know maybe something in
the neighborhood of David Harbor that
would have been amazing that would have
been incredible and story wise
there's no reason to not do that there's
no narrative reason
why he's this buff again
and it doesn't really help that while we
do have another character who could
probably be described as fat that being
Zeus
I don't think Russell Crowe has a fat
suit in that he he might if he does all
previous complaints apply
um but even if he doesn't
you know the one other fact that we see
is depicted as
uncaring a jerk self-centered just not a
good guy so
that doesn't help either
I think it would have been
the coolest damn thing if they just let
Chris Hemsworth look as much like a
normal person as Chris Hemsworth is
gonna look like and like I said still
have the muscles you know the good
shoulder muscles but like not zero body
fat ripped super exaggerated ABS let him
have a dad bod and I don't even know how
comfortable I am with that phrase I have
mixed feelings about it but like you
understand what I mean when I say that
let them just have it how cool would it
have been if when Zeus did that flick
and his clothes flew off and he just had
not this completely unattainable body
and everybody still fainted from how hot
he was I think that would have been
incredible
I would appraised that forever
I'm not going to because it didn't
happen
and it really does unfortunately
undercut some of the value that was
there in end game because it turns it
into a one-off
it says that okay well while we were
okay letting him be heroic while being
fat you know we're past that now we
don't want that for him anymore it's in
a mission that it's unappealing and not
allowable as a norm it would have been
really cool if they just let it be the
new Norm
for Thor and again like I said not
necessarily the fat suit but just
a little bit of fat on the guy that's
going to go down as a major missed
opportunity for representation and yes
fat representation
is a thing
and again that's not necessarily
something I'm going to do deep dive on
because I'm not sure how well equipped I
am to deal with it but like
seeing people like yourself
and seeing them get to be something
other than only one thing so in the case
of a lot of fat people getting to see
them be something other than a punch
line
or other than a tragic story of
depression that has value
most people do not never will and can't
ever look like Chris Hemsworth looks in
anything other than how he looked in
endgame if only for the fact that they
are not being paid literally paid to
work out six hours a day with a physical
trainer for months in lead up to a film
people have jobs they have limited
budgets they can't eat that lien they
don't have that free time they don't
have that kind of energy
they have as much right to have a
superhero that looks at least a little
like them just one so those are my
somewhat rambling thoughts on fat Thor
and sort of using it to touch on some of
the overall issues with body depictions
in Hollywood especially but kind of
media in general and I have a very
strong feeling I am going to be deleting
a lot lot of comments because I again
I've heard them all much like I've heard
the three things said to every trans
person and I delete those comments as
well you know all the you'll never be a
woman uh you're a threat to women you're
a groomer like I've heard it I've heard
it change the record I delete it I know
all the standard things that are said to
fat people again not from experience
they generally not said to me so I'm not
trying to say I've heard directed to me
but like I've heard all of the it's okay
to bully you because we're trying to
encourage you to be better you're gonna
die we're concerned about you you're not
concerned about fat people you want them
to feel shame because you don't like
looking at them they don't have to feel
shame fat shaming does not and has never
helped anybody lose weight it just makes
them feel terrible about themselves
people who feel terrible about
themselves rarely feel motivated to make
major life changes they just sink into
depression so you're not helping anybody
with comments like that you're just
being a cruel [ __ ]
and I'll delete your comments if you're
going to try and do that
so uh with that understanding
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon is what pays the
bills around here allows me to do this
as my living
um and if you can help out in any amount
it does allow me to pay my bills and
keeps me fed
but even if you can't
like share subscribe that helps out as
well
but what I really want you to remember
is that no matter your size no matter
your body
you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
end credits that means I need to shout
out my top Patron supporters Robin Moore
zupin fulla to rock the thing that goes
doing in the anime Oliver B Linda
Walters emu Delhi Leo the Boyd toy lowly
Becky Sparks bernabi likes the poodle
Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor Shea lugurley Brendan Larose and
TT
thank you so much for your support you
can get your name in the credits too by
checking out the rewards on the patreon
you only try deep my earring once this
time that's much better
[Music]